this clearly falsifies the predictions
of the neural network model for why
children show a u-shaped developmental
curve it's a very effective argument
there is one thing though your graph
plots the percentage of regular verb
types not verb tokens and your sample
sizes are quite small since the token
frequency of irregular is in the
language is much higher than the
regulars
you've probably under sampled your
regular verbs which would distort your
ratio I know this is an area of special
interest to you Alice and I have to say
I agree if your paradoxical that the
regular irregular didn't change during
development I mean I understand Alice's
point you'd need samples that are an
order of larger magnitude some kind of
unbiased estimator of the ratio that
took token frequency into account thank
you
Sondra I don't have any specific
comments I just wanted to say how
thoughtful Leslie's presentation was I
know if you worked hard on it and it
really paid off well there's no your
graph plots the percentage of regular
verb types not verb tokens and your
sample sizes are quite small since the
token frequency of a regular is in the
language is much higher than the
regulars you've probably under sampled
your regular verbs which would distort
your ratio